تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو طريفا انتشر لفتاه تحاول تزويد
سيارتها من نوع تسلا بالوقود ويبدو انها
لا تعلم ان سيارتها يتم شحنها بالكهرباء
حيث خرجت من السياره وبدات في البحث عن
خزان الوقود وبدات في حيره نتابع
[موسيقى]
كما تداوله مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي يظهروا صيدا جزائريا يصطادوا
سمكه نادره ومخيفه هي احد الشواطئ السمكه
تشبه الى حد كبير الثعبان وتتميز بثمن
دائريه الشكل وتلتصق بالاشياء بشده مثل
المغناطيس وتعرف هذه السمكه بالجلك البحري
او السمكه المصاصه للدما
[موسيقى]
في المباراه الشهيره بين ريال مدريد
ومانشستر سيتي انتشر مقطع فيديو واثقوا
لحظه قيام والد اللعب هالاند بتبادل
الاهانات مع جماهير النادي الاسباني
واستفزازهم بحركات يده وهو ما تسبب في
طرده من الملعب وفي رد فعل غير لائق قام
هالاند الاب برمي الطعام عليهم نشاهد
[تصفيق]
لحظات مرعبه عاشتها عائله امريكيه بسبب
صخره فضائيه سقطت على منزلهم وتركت ثقبا
مخيفا في السقف بولايه نيوجيرسي واشارت
صاحبه المنزل الى انها عثرت على صخره
معدنيه في زاويه الغرفه وبحسب تصريح علماء
الفلك فان العثور على نيزك يضرب منزلا في
الواقع امر غير عادي ويحدث مرات قليله جدا
في التاريخ
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات